voyons pas content je me rends compte
que ce mariage serait une énormité une
sinécure
une gabegie tu le sais bien que ce
mariage serait une gabegie est ce que
c'est une gabegie au prétoire une
gabegie sait quelque chose
écoute je suis pas là pour te donner des
leçons de français mais pour te rappeler
train de voir si ces femmes sont folles
tu n'as pas besoin d'en profiter
réponds moi panis tu as épousé la petite
tout juste pourquoi tel est mon bon
plaisir
willy de dieu permets moi de te dire
comme vieux monsieur qui épouse une
fille est ce n'est pas joli joli c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait déplaisant
c'est quelque chose qui me déplaît et
ben moi ça me déplaît pas ah oui tu
viens de faire voir le fond de thonidé
tu épouse fanny parce qu'il est jeune et
jolie que tu serais bien content de
frotter sa jolie peau fraîche que tu
retournes vieux cuir de sangliers ne
savait pas pour ça mais c'est un peu
pour ça tu me dégoûtes je suis dégoûté
cet endroit soit les goûters que
voudrait que tu ne me dégoûte pas je
voudrais que dans ces circonstances
graves et familiale tu te comportes
comme un gentilhomme provincial et non
pas comme le dernier des magouilles est
ici ça me plaît à moi de me conduire
comme le ver de bancoule 1 si tu ne suis
pas les conseils de son vieil ami je
serais obligé le jour de ses noces
devenir t'attendre devant l'église à la
sortie non à la rentrée et qu'est ce que
tu veux dire à la première chose que je
te dirai ce sera une grande coup de
marteau sur le crâne thumann tard et
après je t'écris un boy et je te dise
père sont quatre coins des bouches du
rhône à sète me donner le moindre coup
de marteau
pourtant le foot coup de revolver est
pas un revolver miniatures depuis l'ag
du show cette tortue monsieur prix voix
et cette tyrannie a duré plus de trente
ans et tu crois que ça va continuer tu
veux empêcher ce mariage du dieu elles
deux balles de revolver je te la fait
tâter la concorde pour pauvre tu as tué
le scaphandre